monsieur bonsoir il ya aujourd'hui un
sentiment d'accablement que traduisent
les réactions venues des hommes
politiques bien sûr mais aussi de tout
ce dignitaire religieux ou simples
citoyens qu'une caméra aucun micro à
écouter à carpentras wire accablement
devant la profanation du cimetière juif
de carpentras et face à cet
antisémitisme parfois banalisée dans la
société française la classe politique se
retrouve dans le consensus de nadine
iations la condamnation est unanimement
partagée sur place il y à l'émotion des
familles et la succession ininterrompue
des officiels patrice volet
jean-françois janvier
déjà maman d'un mois
le champ des familles juives pour
pleurer les morts d'ogier comme si
carpentras avait remonté le temps cet
après midi pour témoigner de leur
solidarité
pierre mauroy françois léotard jean
claude bodin jack lang
harlem désir les mêmes mots la honte
l'horreur l'inquiétude familles
meurtries celle de maurice benassaya sa
mère sa femme sont enterrés ici c'était
leur havre de paix la révolte monte face
à la lâcheté anonyme et toujours la
crainte de l'oubli or jamais que ville
remplie d'histoires vivent comme cap en
train puis subir qu'on puisse profané
son histoire cette par contre a été un
exemple pour le monde et europe 1 il
faut que tous les jeunes chenilles pour
lutter contre l'ignorance contre un et
dix ans 180 contre on your ans ils
lutteront en même temps contre les
médisances contre calomnie contre la
violence et comprenne qu'elle soit une
haine gratuite ou une haine raciale
mais qui pourra ignorer ne plus se
souvenir que cet homme a été sorti de
son tombeau empalé sur un pieu une
seconde mort son épouse ne l'acceptent
pas au moins et brisé déjà que j'ai
perdu mon mari est à présent de l'europe
on a avalé je peux pas me mettre dans
l'idée ne semble même pas des personnes
mais eni et se disent non alors le jeune
et qu'elle était prête et les mots
notres quelque part il a choisi de
rester seul face à sa douleur
ce soir au cimetière juif de carpentras
reste quelques fleurs et une immense
indignation